nous en avons marre nous avons voyez
déjà un préavis de grève sur deux jours
à la direction depuis mardi dont six
otages ne sont pas pris au sérieux donc
la halle nous en avons marre parce que
nous avons déjà été mobilisés au mois de
février pendant cinq jours vous avez
fait des promesses qui ne sont toujours
pas respectés les travaux l'eau chaude
tout tout ce qui concerne notre
l'hygiène et la santé à la clinique
l'analyse on nous en avons marre ça fait
des années que ça dure ça fait 12 ans
que le coût de capa est en place et
renier notre fonctionne il y en a marre
de travail dans ces conditions là c'est
le personnel qui fait la clinique
jusqu'à maintenant son plein au peyrouat
santé à la population tout ce qui se
passe à la quinine
nous avons les exemples devant nous
avons les bouillants tout ça pour voir
comment on baigne quand même les
patients nous les changeons de l'eau au
métier même si c'est pas normal
la direction seul manque du personnel et
aussi la patiente elle paraissait qui
les privait ne peut pas être dans cet
état
le finalement cette mobilisation c'est
le prolongement de la première des
milliers 2010 est exactement toujours
des promesses non tenues donc là nous
sommes pas des enfants
c'est bien une nouvelle mais il y en a
marre là y'en a marre donc là nous
disons stop ça suffit en tout cas pas
qu'ils prennent leurs responsabilités
nous voulons des engagements clairs et
précis il au bain avant le
renouvellement des chambres la
climatisation dans les chambres l'eau
chaude tout ça rien n'est fait jusqu'à
maintenant en plus 11 7 a prévu pour
juin de juin 2010 est à jeun 2020
rien n'est fait rien n'est respecté nous
allons à l'adresse postale mans les
autorités compétentes le salarié comme
nation n'a pris jusqu'à maintenant